en nuestro tema del día en directo
américa es el primer año en el poder de
joe biden como presidente de eeuu que
cumple hoy 20 de enero 2022 en nuestro
primer bloque analizamos cómo ha sido la
gestión del mandatario hasta hoy
atravesada por la pandemia de la
inflación y la retirada el ejército
estadounidense de afganistán
365 días después bailén cerró con una
popularidad en descenso y en una rueda
de prensa admitió algunos fallos aunque
defendió su campaña contra el nuevo
coronavirus y la creación de empleos del
jefe de la casa blanca también habló
sobre los proyectos de ley pendientes
sobre gasto social y el derecho al voto
ahora se adentra en un año electoral en
el que se renovarán parcialmente el
senado y la cámara del nuevo balance en
el congreso depende el cumplimiento de
su agenda y para entonces conversar
sobre este tema está con nosotros
antonella martín analista política y
directora en atlas network gracias a
antonella por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de francés 24 ya
hablamos entonces con nuestro primer
invitado del balance de bailén ahora
hablemos de los retos que tiene el
mandatario estos tres años que le quedan
así en buenos días efectivamente veíamos
que a lo largo de un año incluso varias
encuestas recientes coinciden en ese
desplome no de la aprobación del
presidente demócrata muchas encuestas de
hecho dejan esa desaprobación en un
promedio de 45 algunas llegan al 55%
creo que estos datos son preocupantes
tienen que llamar la atención como bien
decías a la hora también de hablar del
balance del congreso que dependerá mucho
de su agenda una agenda además a lo
largo de este año marcada por el joven
19 afganistán incluso todavía temas que
preocupan a la hora de digamos el
fracaso a la hora de revertir esas
políticas migratorias de la gestión
anterior de donald trump y por supuesto
la inflación no que no es un dato menor
ahora antonella hablemos de esa
inflación y la economía cómo puede hacer
el presidente yo vaivén para
contrarrestarla para poder solucionar
esta inflación que también viene de la
mano de la crisis en la cadena de
suministros en el país
efectivamente creo que el punto central
para entender esa inflación y también
para atacar esa inflación y poder
resolverla reside y está el punto
principal en la fed en la reserva
federal de los eeuu por un lado lo que
ha emitido descontroladamente el dinero
nosotros bien sabemos que digamos la
emisión monetaria
lo primero que causa como consecuencia
principal es la inflación entonces
tenemos que marcar ese punto ese detalle
entendiendo que estados unidos tienen
vemos una tasa de inflación interanual
de casi 7% que es la mayor cifra
básicamente registrada en los últimos 39
años y además empezar a hacer recortes
dentro del gasto público porque así es
como vemos los países resuelven el
problema de déficit entonces hoy estamos
viendo un problema que está relacionado
a una inflación como consecuencia de una
emisión monetaria con un banco central
que emite dinero de una manera
descontrolada a gasto público que sigue
aumentando y por supuesto una deuda que
también digamos viene creciendo desde
hace ya mucho tiempo por esto es una
política muy irregular muy típica de
básicamente las últimas a lo largo de
las últimas gestiones en los eeuu
antonio y hablemos también de otro tema
que preocupa a la comunidad
internacional y también al gobierno del
presidente de bailén de la mano de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris porque ella
es la encargada de la inmigración sobre
todo de centroamérica que va hacia eeuu
como pueden ellos entonces contrarrestar
esta inmigración que causa tragedias y
muertes a estas personas que buscan una
vida mejor en estados unidos y como lo
van a solucionar estos tres años que le
quedan por delante es el gobierno
demócrata bueno sobre ese punto y es muy
interesante y creo que los
latinoamericanos también nos llama mucho
la atención y es algo que nos preocupa
no a la hora de repensar incluso no sólo
viéndolo desde la entrada a los estados
unidos sino también preguntarnos en este
caso como análisis político porque nos
vamos de nuestros países a lo largo de
américa latina es decir porque no
tenemos instituciones sólidas que nos
garanticen un cuidado de la propiedad
privada de las libertades de los
individuos entonces existe existe esa
constante necesidad de migrar de salir
de nuestros países y buscar algo mejor
el punto principal acá que hay que
entender es que necesitamos y que el
mundo incluso necesita apostar por una
inmigración mucho más libre en digamos
las gestiones anteriores han abocado
mucho el punto de la inmigración legal
pero ese es un tema que además ha sido
muy complejo porque han hablado de
inmigración legal a la alavesa han hecho
que esa inmigración legal sea cada vez
más compleja y complicada a la hora de
alcanzarla no con más trabas más
regulaciones más burocracias a la hora
de conseguir esas visas no sé creo que
el punto acá está en entender el
concepto de la inmigración y entender
que la inmigración es básicamente la
historia de homo sapiens es la historia
de los seres humanos es decir que todos
venimos de un mismo lugar y entender la
importancia de abrir esas esas fronteras
y de hacer mucho más accesible y de no
caer en esos argumentos que nos dicen
que es por el estado de bienestar por lo
que vienen los inmigrantes cuando eso en
realidad es una gran palabra de hecho
cuando un inmigrante llega a eeuu
básicamente tiene que esperar entre 5 y
6 años para acceder a los beneficios de
ese estado de bienestar entonces cortar
con ese mecanismo y empezar a abrir
fronteras creo que es el punto inicial
para que debería ser el gran desafío
también para esta nueva gestión auto
liga también hablamos de algo pendiente
y algo que le preocupa a la optimización
demócrata del presidente o padre que son
estas elecciones de medio término cómo
llegan los demócratas a estas elecciones
los republicanos digamos pueden ganar
terreno en estas nuevas elecciones
también el presidente de bailén habló en
algún momento de una posible reelección
de lanzarse nuevamente a la presidencia
en tres años en las próximas elecciones
presidenciales cómo llega baiden a esta
reelección y realmente el presidente si
va a poder decir pues yo me voy a lanzar
a la reelección con esta popularidad en
descenso y depende también de lo que
pasa en estas elecciones de medio
término
claramente yo creo que es muy poco
probable que el presidente joe biden
vaya por el camino o al menos intentar
esa reelección en un segundo mandato
primero obviamente por la edad del
presidente pero también esto dependerá
mucho no porque eso es una segunda parte
pero esto como punto principal dependerá
mucho de lo que vaya a hacer esta
gestión como bien decías con esa
desaprobación que ha ido en alza en este
en este año con números que nos llaman
mucho la atención a la hora de ver la
imagen negativa que tiene el presidente
joe biden y creo que ese balance incluso
dentro del congreso en esas elecciones
dependerá también de lo que vaya a hacer
la agenda en los próximos años y como
además se haga frente a los problemas y
los desafíos que todavía no se han
podido cumplir entendiendo también que
algo que ha marcado mucho ese primer año
ha sido la pandemia obviamente del 2019
creo que el delta y omicron también
terminaron de marcar muchos de los
puntos
hablar de esta gestión así que creo que
dependerá mucho el balance incluso de
ese congreso esas elecciones de lo que
vas a hacer la agenda y cómo se haga
frente a estos desafíos muy rápidamente
han torera no quiero que se me quede por
fuera la crisis climática recordemos que
el presidente vaya envolvió al acuerdo
de país pero que tanto ha hecho eeuu
para cambiar para mitigar el efecto de
los gases de efecto invernadero en
nuestro planeta
si claramente ese es otro punto que
tiene que ponerse sobre la mesa que creo
que no solamente los eeuu sino que el
resto de la comunidad internacional
tiene que empezar a prestar atención a
la hora de hablar del cuidado y el
cambio de el cambio climático y el
cuidado del medio ambiente creo sin
embargo que los impuestos y quizás las
trabas regulatorias y hacer cada vez más
complejo el proceso
empresarial cuando uno habla en estos
términos no es la solución sino empezar
a crear y generar esa conciencia a la
hora de hablar del medio ambiente pero
es un punto clave y fundamental también
para lo que vaya a hacer los desafíos
claramente de esta gestión